>>> TONIGHT TRUMP D HIS ALLIES
FANNING THE FLAMES AND PUSHING
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AS THEY TRY
TO GET AHEAD OF WHATEVER THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT MAY NOW HAVE.
>> WHY ARE THEY RIFLING THROUGH
HIS DESK?
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO INDICT HIM.
THEY UNDERSTAND HE'S THE LEADER
OF THE MOST POWERFUL POLITICAL
MOVEMENT IN MODERN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
I ACTUALLY THINK IN ALL OF
AMERICAN HISTORY.
>> DREW GRIFFIN IS OUT FRONT.
DREW, YOU'VE DONE SO MUCH
REPORTING ON THE PARANOIA, THE
FEAR BEING STOKED BY TRUMP
ALLIES LIKE STEVE BANNON.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING RIGHT NOW?
>> TO TRY TO UNDERSTAND THE
MADNESS OF IT, YOU HAVE TO
APPROACH IT, ERIN, FROM THEIR
PERSPECTIVE, WHICH IS A WAR
BETWEEN GOOD AND EVIL.
THE ENTIRE PREMISE OF THE FAR
RIGHT MEDIA IS THIS LIE THAT JOE
BIDEN IS ELLIE LE JIT MAT
PRESIDENT, ILLEGALLY ELECTED AND
BIDEN IS SURROUNDED BY THIS ARMY
OF WASHINGTON INSIDERS CALLED
THE DEEP STATE THAT IS DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO STOP
TRUMP FROM RUNNING AGAIN.
STEVE BANNON, TRUMP'S FORMER
CHIEF STRATEGIST, HE RUNS WITH
THIS EXPANDING FALSE CONSPIRACY
DAILY ON HIS PODCAST.
IT GROWS AND GROWS WITH EVERY
NEWS EVENT.
WHEN FBI AGENTS SERVE A WARRANT
ON TRUMP'S RESORT, THE RHETORIC
EXPLODES ACCUSING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND FBI AGENTS OF
ACTING LIKE, WHAT ELSE?
NAZIS.
>> THIS WHOLE RAID, THIS JACK
BOOTED GESTAPO-LIKE RAID BY THE
FBI WAS ABOUT RANSACKING AND
DESECRATING MAR-A-LAGO.
THEY KNEW WHAT THIS MEANT TO THE
NATION.
THEY KNEW WHAT IT MEANT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, THEY KNEW WHAT
IT MEANT TO MOG GA.
THEY'RE THERE TO PLANT STUFF.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE SILENT.
YOU'RE TOTAL SCUM BAGS.
YOU'RE LAWLESS.
YOU'VE TURNED THIS THING INTO A
POLITICAL WEAPON.
IT'S A DISGRACE.
>> BANNON HAS TOLD HIS VIEWERS
THAT TRUMP COULD BE ASSASSINATED
BY THE DEEP STATE TO STOP TRUMP
FROM RUNNING AGAIN.
THIS IS WHAT HIS AUDIENCE IS FED
DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
IT'S NOT NEWS.
WE KNOW FROM LISTENING TO HIS
OWN LISTENERS THEY BELIEVE IT,
ERIN.
>> SO INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS,
DREW.
WE KNOW IT'S EXTREME.
BANNON'S LISTENERS MAY BELIEVE
ALL OF IT.
THEY MAY BELIEVE IT.
WHEN I USE THE WORD DANGEROUS,
THAT IS THE QUESTION.
HOW FAR DOES THIS GO IN TERMS OF
ITS IMPACT?
>> THAT'S WHY, UNFORTUNATELY, WE
REPORT ON STEVE BANNON
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE HE'S PART
OF THE TRUMP PARTY.
DAVID CHALIAN CALLS HIM THE
INTELLECTUAL NAVIGATOR FOR THE
PARTY, SETTING THE AGENDA EVEN
MORE THAN DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE SO MANY OF
THESE FRINGE CONGRESSPEOPLE,
THEY SHOW UP ON BANNON'S SHOW.
>> IT'S AMAZING, AS YOU POINT
OUT.
BACK IN THE DAY WHEN PEOPLE
TALKED ABOUT HIM AS A PUPPETERE.
THAT AGENDA YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
IS LONG TERM.
>> EXTREMELY LONG TERM.
RIGHT NOW FOCUSED ON THE
MIDTERMS.
BUT THE BIG AGENDA HERE FOR THIS
VERSION OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY,
THEY WANT TO TAKE OVER ALL OF IT
IN SCHOOL BOARDS TO
CONGRESSIONAL SEATS.
THEN TAKE OVER CONGRESS THIS
FALL.
TRUMP BACK IN THE WHITE HOUSE IN
2024, AND ERIN, TO TAKE OVER THE
GOVERNMENT WHICH THEY MEAN TO
GET RID OF THE BUREAUCRATS, THE
DEEP STATE, GET RID OF THE FBI,
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, ALL
OF IT, TRANSFORM THE UNITED
STATES.
THIS IS WHAT THEY